sexuellement je te demande plus comment
ça va parce que la dernière fois que
sept minutes comme en salle est il m'a
dit je te demande quel droit tu te mets
toi je te souviens que j'ai fait en plus
là aujourd'hui c'est que je vais faire
plus soif qu'est-ce que tu est
allergique aux bananes a pas dit oui
tout dit ou bien voilà la banane le
fruit de tous les plaisirs le moins
fatigante à éplucher le plus drôle à
manger mais voilà si vous êtes
allergique à ce fruit inoffensif
sachez que vous l'êtes aussi aux
préservatifs il s'agit d'une découverte
sérieuse révélée par une équipe de
scientifiques belges
les personnes qui présentent une
intolérance à la banane ou à la
châtaigne peuvent dès le premier contact
avec un préservatif faire des réactions
violentes
une réaction de sensibilisation ou latex
se manifeste parce que ce qu'on appelle
un syndrome de rigueur de contacts parmi
nos premiers malades nous avons
rencontré une patiente qui présentait le
tableau spécifique de cette allergie au
latex c'est-à-dire intolérance aux gones
à theix sans préservatif en latex ainsi
que la châtaigne et la baleine j' ai
mangé beaucoup de bananes vraiment trois
quatre fois par semaine je mangeais une
banane avec m à tartiner j'ai jamais eu
de problème et un moment c'est arrivé
une banane et c'était là la première
fois que mon mari employé un préservatif
j'avais des problèmes tout de suite ça
chatouille est et l'entourage était tout
à fait gonfler il est en rapport évident
lorsqu'on regarde une banane on
s'aperçoit que c'est une plante
monocotylédones de la famille des
herbacées ne pas confondre avec la cedh
il a mis nos idoles stifani la cinat et
la chose est tout à fait normal quand on
est allergique à la banane on l'est au
préservatif
le coupable serait donc une protéine
commune a la banane et au latex qui
composent les préservatifs
un souci de plus pour les fabricants et
distributeurs de capotes ici à l'essai
nous ne sommes pas au courant de cette
affaire dans l'hypothèse où ces
recherches s'avèrent positives nous
sommes prêts à en informer le
consommateur sur notre emballage
mentionnant la présence ces protéines
temps
qu'allah banal on l'est aussi au
préservatif s de l'info s de l'intox
alain richard je te le demande
info info pourquoi je sais pas ouais pas
de perdre tout cas trop le plein il me
kyi info ou intox
un fou pourquoi si c'est vrai et comment
tu sais ça je suis allergique aux
bananes
et toi alors à ton avis et de la foule
intox moi je dis que c'est un truc
inventé par les mecs qui ne veulent pas
mettre les capotes star de bananes vas-y
je suis allergique à la banale a donc je
ne vais pas de cap evans a pas d'accord
ça continue je vais y est aussi
allergique à la banane alors c'est un
sujet qui nous a été envoyé par madame
marie kraft sud de maurepas qui gagne
déjà 2000 francs parce qu'on a tourné
son sujet maintenant pour savoir si je
rajoute - thierry ardisson mille francs
de ma poche on écoute la réponse
les personnes qui présentent un syndrome
d'urticaire de contacts au latex l'offre
quand même être prévenu de certains
dangers
étant donné que plusieurs cas ont été
décrits nous l'on a observé de symptômes
sévères et même des cas mortels savais
toi j'ai regardé la tête de jean pierre
j'aurais dû suis déjà sur le premier
coup
et toi je te dis je tu sais qui tu as
perdu tu vois c'est pas un truc
inventive par les mecs pour pas mettre
de capote à kamenar parce que j aime
toujours à ce jour et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu